pendant longtemps on a été persuadé que
un être humain égale un ADN alors qu'en
fait non dans les cas de chimérisme
complet un être humain égal deux ADN
voire plus mais déjà deux séries Sims
c'est genre une centaine de cas décrit
dans la littérature scientifique alors
plus on en parle même pas mais alors une
chimère est-ce que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui est sa propre jumelle ou
son propre jumeau bah un peu mais pas
vraiment à la base du chimérisme il y a
des jumelles ou des jumeaux ça c'est
vrai donc il y a des chimères c'est des
jumeaux dizygote sauf que là c'est deux
ovules fécondées qui sont censés devenir
de fœtus puis de bébé etc ils vont
fusionner donc au final pour schématiser
on peut dire qu'on a un seul foetus avec
les caractéristiques génétiques des deux
embryons qui ont fusionné donc avec deux
ADN faut pas vraiment dire qu'une
chimère et sa propre jumelle c'est juste
deux embryons confusionnés pour devenir
une seule personne donc oui cette
personne elle a deux ADN mais on peut
pas dire qu'il y a la sienne et celle de
son frère ou de sa sœur les deux sont à
elle